[Music]
in church sin news all submitted by two
Direction porn stars who film themselves
having sex in a confessional box are
cleared of any charges why they clean
well they're confessing at the exact
same time so they're clearing their
charge that's really strong they're
saying Hail Marys while they're doing it
how the [ __ ] they got balls wait where
are they porn stars - I always loved
that are they porn stars they're just
amateur porn shooter guys nowadays it's
hard to tell yeah you never the Union
words or what what separates the talent
caliber only dicks you've ever had in
you mm-hmm yeah that's definitely
involved I have no idea calling on porn
stars so this takes place in Holland
they're not porn stars the prostitute
probably really [ __ ] hot didn't live
in Van Nuys Iran and they have to have
like a porn star name so it's a Dutch
porn star named Kim Holland it's too
normal
it's uh huh it's got to be like Lisa you
take the name of your first pet and then
the street you lived on when you're a
child
all right so mine would be pumpkin
Ponderosa that's strong that's nice
mine's lucky yes woods that's good dude
Tyson Felson in the street yeah that you
grew up on myself else it's pretty good
- is that a taboo carriage Burt wait
first pet's names like in the street
that you grew up on yeah Joe Denker wait
your first pet's name was Joe yes why
was your name was your dad named Joe -
he just needed everything Joe they're
like white what do you want to name the
dog and I was like Joe the best name
yeah my name's the best name named my
first stuffed animal Nikki Nicole oh I
thought you had tough Asian parents dude
no they're like are you sure you want to
name them that I'm like yeah it's a dope
name it's my name what you had to say my
dad would have been like that's your
name No
I had way kinder parents than you why
choose that time to stand up for the dog
down here actually what would your dad
and said to my grandpa who's name was
Ben and named all of his sons Ben that's
true my dad and his two brothers are
named Ben and his dad's name - it's like
the George Foreman thing but maybe he
draws a line when you name the animal
like it's a you can't do that you know
yeah and he's like you should use like
your mother's [ __ ] named Ben it
shocked me yeah thank you Julie's a
secret freak though you don't know Julia
no I do know I've heard word on the
street Oh Bing I heard from your
boyfriend oh yeah of course
who I never met who is he I want to know
his name me too bro I know I want to
meet him I met at one time he walked
past me to go use the bathroom of my
office didn't even say hi to me what was
he wearing a mask you still never
brought him back so you can redeem
himself because he has work on the
weekend so my fault like this what's
your point I know my point is that
whenever you guys have gatherings on the
weekends I tried to bring him over but
then I ended up bring him cuz he has
work we don't gather on the weekend
this is this is when you all gather
stories falling apart its falling apart
Julie it's [ __ ] terrible feelin real
he's real he is real because he directed
to the freaking Smashing Pumpkins
concert what's his favorite what's his
favorite TV show yeah he likes it but
it's not that you know one's favorite TV
show good show but you can't be
passionate about you ever see somewhere
community show yeah sure sure
that's true you know I'm saying what's
his favorite band let's look at music do
something
it was him pumpkins know what's his
middle name three two one doesn't even
know I don't want to say it I rather not
oh you want to keep him secret from the
she's protecting yeah it's like
non-existent no look it up it's just his
name is all one word it isn't really she
that was correct I've seen it with a
million followers anyway I'm tired of
all these lies Julia please break porn
stars doing in their confessionals yes
oh he's a porn star and this man in this
crew
they all went to this charge crew or
like a one-man crew painting I was
picturing a guy what a [ __ ] phone and
two people [ __ ] yes and you probably
recorded it this way to you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I know what is it I'm not
religious by any means but I still feel
like that's so disrespectful to people
that are because they go in there to
like
mourn or asleep and yeah it's someone
[ __ ]
how dare you piece of [ __ ] I just hope
that they brought like booty wipes and
then they were able to clean after they
did that a section public legal in
Holland what makes you think it would be
I know
no hookers there and weed I got no
problem with it you guys are a bunch of
frickin Puritans really yeah then I
think it's fine no response they confirm
you know respect respect no it's not I
look I get the respect argument but I
don't know I have to take a little light
diddling it's the house of God if
someone was in your house [ __ ] did
would they be allowed to do that yeah
apparently public that strange in public
public sex yes let's do it
honey we've been looking for an excuse
we go back to answers we've been in
Amsterdam is it like so fun out there
like they have all these things that are
legal but people aren't going bananas
it's like they're more well-mannered
than it's not taboo it's only like
people go crazy when it's something
taboo they're getting away with it
so if you let them do it then people
like be like I don't want to do anymore
but I don't think that they can do that
now like because I think they they tried
that yeah it's not that bad like like
for example in LA right like yo we see
people going way over the speed limit
but if this [ __ ] was like taxes do ya
Autobot exactly one car that's going
like 200 miles an hour contradicting
link saying that public said sex is
illegal I don't know whoa let's do it
and see if we get caught well if it's
legal because if you're walking your
favorite trends yeah I didn't see anyone
[ __ ] on the street well this leader
in the winter though might be cool yeah
we went to the during the winter too
yeah you don't [ __ ] I like once
you're up there no winner just cozy
moving yeah no I like being bundled up
oh that's true my dicks like shrinks
like an age during the where yeah I
don't [ __ ] it goes inside yeah we keep
our clothes on
no wonder you stay indoors and it's hot
and you want get naked nah man
I keep the socks on hmm you yeah it's
the time to make snow angels yeah anyway
this couple they uploaded the video
online oh they're a couple
no couple I don't know they don't help
people I never seen partners so they
incriminating themselves by posting this
video but what happens if they posted
some evidence of something yep
caught red-handed buddy yeah you didn't
think you'd get caught would you
some people don't post any evidence of
anything at all tell delicate stories we
see we're never gonna be close to you
cuz we're gonna [ __ ] about you yeah we
can't roast your guy we don't know no
way we can get closer to is when you
show everything on social media
mm-hmm we don't know anything about you
your name my friend see we don't even
know you expose them for the views like
you know dude you know it's weird no not
gonna exploit him kisses he gets up you
know what's weird about her dude I never
even seen her go to the bathroom okay
walk into the bathroom room never one
time like frickin five times today you
win you know what you did you went in
and you turned the lights off no you
stood in there to act more human-like
didn't ya oh you can't tell the cheese
and avoid some she doesn't mean um no
that's what that's not a human she's bad
at you were good until the lights off
yeah I think that's the preferred way
that's right guys you guys definitely
turn your attention on me and not the
suspicious more that's one damn mafia
all over again dad let's go right now
you'll lose mafia right now it is again
so are they in trouble so prosecutors
found that there was nothing that they
can there was no punishable offense
because there are no blasphemy laws well
I don't know if it's like blast like
like sex in public yeah that's like you
don't have a rule where you can't
[ __ ] side Church so I guess you guys
are off the hook can you fund in a toy
store yeah what if they go into a
grocery store us they also [ __ ] in a
shopping mall elevator and a parking
garage so maybe it is legal is this
[ __ ] elevator or how many stories
that they go how the buttons but that
means it stops yeah this is opening
closer still [ __ ] or they could hit
the emergency stop thing dude I bet you
a tribe of Indians would find a like
like a crazy like tribe like in the
middle of like Nairobi or some [ __ ] like
we're nobody's scenes anyone they would
see an elevator and they'd find it to be
a holy site and so that the in fact
[ __ ] in an elevator it's pretty
disrespect I think way if you think
about it oh my god you ever jerk off the
church hope you guys enjoyed that video
but if you didn't guess what you can
directly contribute to the Articles that
we discussed just cruise on over to the
description box below click on that link
to submit your article also for the next
video
Vick rat up hey
you
[Music]